what does that mean in japanese
pisu helmet means to [ __ ]
and peace peace peace is peace all right
peace [ __ ]
peace [ __ ] i'm fair enough yeah um so
the premise of this one was a strange
one okay uh there was like i guess uh
who's do you think it is first of all
yours yeah i thought it was yours this
seemed very much like a human thing
yeah but i also really really like the
plot to this one yeah i really enjoyed
the plot
i loved it yeah it was very good the
plot was good so okay first of all i did
read
the i was very very confused because it
came with like a
prequel yeah that's that's that's like
the youtube hook right right
where where you have like a few pages to
hook in the reader where it was just
like a bunch of
girls who have been taking photos of who
are naked yeah and i was very confused
and then when i started reading it i
almost forgot for a second i was i was
reading and dojin because i thought i
was about to get some kind of sick
[ __ ]
epic dojin about kendo
like just for a second i totally forgot
that i was reading porn
yeah i was i thought this was like a
regular moment i escaped into a regular
manga
you know there was this you have this
little you know the
the chad woman who is this amazing kendo
player very attractive very beautiful
and like the
simp guy who's like this very tiny very
wimpy looking character yeah
yeah and then for some reason during the
story she's like oh please can you help
me with something yeah obviously the the
wimpy character is like yes of course
i'll help you
so they go to the office and there's the
guy who's in charge of the kendo club
who's engaged to the the girl
is he a student i don't know if that's
he's a student but he's literally built
like a [ __ ] whale
on steroids like this man is absolutely
tall that's generous like 15 feet tall
muscular you know and he's like this is
my this is my fiance yeah by the way
i need you to take photos of all the
women at the school all the graduates
all right all the graduates
naked being [ __ ] anything
and then there's just so many quotes in
this are just very funny yeah to me
because
and then he's like oh is that a the
little wimpy characters like oh is it
okay that we take sexual photos of the
girls it's like
oh yes all the girls have given their
consent to this literally
really yeah because of the long-standing
tradition in the city it's a
long-standing tradition i'm like this is
like some youtuber cancel baby
how is this this is this is a tweet
longer waiting to blow up man how does
this become a long set
i want to know that backstory who
started this how did everyone just come
to this village
how did everyone give concern i feel
like this needs to be like a sign form
or something like i really want to know
more of this story there must be an
ironclad contract to this yeah
release waivers so many funny uh
they have given their okay to this
that's what they said what i appreciate
about this dojon is that
i always appreciate a doujin where it
takes more than 20 pages to get to the
[ __ ]
yeah right i appreciate that a lot about
it because because i literally
experienced
two hours of just the worst [ __ ] i read
the armor one before this
i was begging for something that wasn't
[ __ ] awful
so this was a breath of fresh air
because the difference between a parody
dozen and an actual dojin is that parody
dozens if you're a fan
of the show the series you you can skip
the context because you know the content
you can build on top of that but like
the the real challenge with just a
plain doujin is that stuff original you
know an original attack on whatever
is that they need to build up your
investment into this story yeah by
itself with no pre-investment
any franchise or whatever and normally
that takes a long time and i can
appreciate when he goes he won like 40
people like a whole chapter i think
almost with no [ __ ] and i'm just like
respect
restraint i appreciate it exactly yeah
one thing i really liked about this one
is that like the whole
i guess point is that like obviously
he's gonna [ __ ] the main girl
yeah but they hold off on it for so
goddamn long yeah i appreciate it wait
so did you read this whole thing
no i read uh about nearly two two
stories so
two chapters yeah the first chapter was
like 150 pages no it wasn't
there's like six parts to this there was
if if you're thinking of the 500 page
one
those are 16 chapters put together yeah
oh well it was
it was when i looked in the website it
said six stories or whatever oh okay
so i mean i read up up until like how
many pages which way which goal did you
get to
which one i think you actually [ __ ]
the girl okay you got further than me
then which is like
i think it's like 200 pages in yeah but
then there's still like 400
more after that yeah which i i didn't
understand but i was still like
all right the story's pretty hot because
the whole premise is that he has to then
go and
he's recruited this this he's doing he's
doing his job
yeah this wimpy kid is recruited to take
all the naked and lewd photos yeah you
know and
if he has to help to get the photos done
he does yeah so he just starts [ __ ]
everyone
yes you do i appreciate the hustle you
know yeah i was like you know what
good for him this is you're not you know
he was scared at first but then he gets
more and more confident yeah
you know ticked all the boxes it was
like consensual attractive
kid coming into his own getting getting
[ __ ]
good for him yeah good i was i was
rooting for him it's a coming-of-age
story yeah
and you know i thought it was very
attractive that she was watching the
whole time
yeah yeah giving moral support who
doesn't want that i love the scene where
she just like comes around and grabs his
dick and he's like you got this
yeah yeah it was like irl twitch chat
yeah with [ __ ] you know
it's like you know he's like paul go in
park take the photos
this is just good i'm surprised you like
this one because i'm surprised you like
this one as well
yeah this didn't see okay because this
one i like i like the long game i like
that they were they were reserved with a
lot of things because this one is one of
my favorite yeah
like of all time yeah the art style
threw me off a little bit in the store
it's unique isn't it but then i got into
it i was like you know what i [ __ ] with
it that's exactly how i felt
and then and then you know because
obviously you can't just have the
gimmick if he goes to take picture he
[ __ ] them
don't get old yeah so they start
introducing like these [ __ ] battles
yeah that's what i liked as well but i'm
just like this is so [ __ ] dumb but
i'm here for it the baiting battles
right yeah yeah yeah yeah
like bet on something yeah the first bet
is that he has to choose
what he thinks is her favorite volumes
of her like lewd outfits am i correct
yeah yeah so she's like
uh like a graveyard model who does like
sexual stuff and she's like
pick two or pick two things that i
consider my best works and he's like
easy game yeah and then if you pick them
out i was already a super fan
[Applause]
and he's like if you lose you throw out
all of your porn if you win
you get to [ __ ] me and he gets the [ __ ]
so congratulations
there was another one where they did
like wishbone breaking
oh yeah yeah with the grass that's like
a really old japanese game
yeah and then he wins i that this
20-foot kendo man is like
um he's so powerful he's won two betting
games
this kid's good and it's like it's like
we need more food like he literally
guest dojins and then played wishbone
a lucky game what do you think yeah yeah
and it's just like he might get all the
photos this year
implying that some of them don't want
their photos taken which is like i was
like oh that's a little weird but i'll
forgive it
yeah but it was supposed to go some of
the later chapters it does become like
that yeah i
i thought you know what fair enough it
was i i see the vision
yeah i appreciate the execution what
all-around good fun for the family
what i love about cheers
for the most part i think i i didn't get
far enough i'm sad you didn't make it to
like the
pretty much like the the finale or like
the enemy part i might refuse the epic
because there's like a whole
[ __ ] there's like three chapters where
there's a there's three chapters where
the wimpy kid the main character fights
the student council brick [ __ ]
in wrestling okay i know they were
building up
yeah yeah it was very obvious that that
was going to be the finale and while
that's happening
all of the girls that he's [ __ ] are
getting like
gang-banged by the entire school and
he's like if you want to stop this
beat me in a wrestling match and i was
just like you know you know i was like
you know after reading all of all of
joey's recommendations i
like figured out joey's tastes like if
there's he recommends a dozen if there's
a panel on it with more than like eight
tits in one panel
that's that's a joey true that's a joke
joey
yeah yeah you're right i can't
you know i'm mad that you're right the
more the merrier yeah
yeah but like what what i love about a
story in indonesian like this is when
like they introduced
the one winning girl at the beginning
sure yeah yeah i mean she's the hottest
you know higher percentage
artists they just know they know they
know i'm going to make this girl the
hottest
there's something about a supporting
girl yeah you just you can't help but
root for you know
you're like she's just helping she's
just doing her part yeah [ __ ] it
yeah literally yeah it's like they must
have like
a talent to be able to like make a girl
that you know
is like just radiates best girl energy
right
like they just radiate best girl energy
and everyone just unanimously agrees
that this is best girl
and every every girl is just like the
losing girl so honestly she wasn't okina
who's the
the artist he's like [ __ ] amazing at
that because all of his other ones
he always introduces this like beginning
girl yeah
and whether like she gets [ __ ] in the
beginning or right at the end
she always ends up being the best girl